[Aplausos]
vocês já pararam para pensar que os
principais problemas da humanidade são
causados por liderança a fome a miséria
a desigualdade as guerras todas as
guerras que já aconteceram e todas que
ainda vão acontecer
a divisão à corrupção a destruição tudo
causado pela liderança
por outro lado a solução de todos os
problemas do mundo podem vir através da
liderança se o líder é parte do problema
parte da solução depende dos valores que
ele tem no coração porque a gente tem
consciência dos poderes da força que tem
os valores são eles que determinam os
nossos pensamentos as nossas ações
os nossos sentimentos os valores valores
definem quem nós somos
no fim das contas e quando nós pensamos
sobre liderança
existem basicamente cinco tipos de
líderes em cinco níveis diferente
o líder de nível 1 vai revelar a pior
versão do que pode ser um ser humano
ele vai apelar para os instintos e
emoções das pessoas
líderes de nível 1 servem a valores como
competição território pressão paixão
vitória e poder
e quanto mais poder e eles têm mais
poder
eles querem são a praga que está na
história da humanidade desde sempre ele
sofre de uma patologia
eles querem ser o número 1
eles estão infiltrados em escolas
hospitais nos governos empresas e se
eles não forem controlados
eles podem causar um mal terrível se
sabe que todos nós temos paz e os
primeiros líderes que nós temos nossa
vida são os nossos pais e país de nível
1 são pais opressores cria uma relação
de dependência emocional ambiente
difícil onde a criança não consegue
expressar a sua verdadeira identidade
são líderes assim que ocupam cargos em
todos os lugares
pode ser um gerente e j o governador
estúpido mas com potencial de se tornar
até hitler líderes de nível 1 oprime as
pessoas mas ainda bem que tem outros
os líderes de nível dois usam a razão
são racionais os líderes de nível dois
servem a valores como observação lógica
entendimento e conhecimento razão e
justiça são líderes de nível 2 que
observam a natureza os acontecimentos as
pessoas ea partir daí criam o
conhecimento são graças a líderes de
nível 2 que nós construímos todo o
conhecimento científico que a humanidade
tem até hoje eles escrevem regras leis
códigos de conduta para poder modelar o
comportamento humano
os pais de nível 2 tem uma preocupação
especial com os filhos
eles querem o melhor para eles um
caminho seguro um caminho estável
eles querem que seus filhos fiquem na
melhor escola possível eles cobram boas
notas e vão influenciar os seus filhos
para ter uma carreira bem sólida
são previsível e de preferência que
pague bem são líderes de nível 2 como
henry ford criou processos procedimentos
uma forma de se fabricar veículos em
série de uma forma que as pessoas
tivessem o melhor resultado possível
líderes de nível 2 escrevem regras
processos normas e leis para que as
pessoas sejam controladas
é isso que os líderes nível dois fazem
mas tem um tipo divertido que eu adoro
os líderes nível 3
hoje ele deu três fazem a inovação são
eles que inventam novas músicas novos
penteados novos ritmos fazem mudanças
empresas em escolas
eles mudam o jeito das pessoas pensar
são pessoas que liberam o potencial das
outras pessoas
eles vivem fazendo modificações eles não
contendo não se contentou com as coisas
como elas são eles questionam as regras
eles acham que o que tá aí pode ser
melhor
pais de nível 3 vou encorajar os seus
filhos a descobrir sua verdadeira
vocação e seguir mesmo que isso não dê
dinheiro porque para um pai de nível 3
o importante é que seu filho se realize
se expresse são líderes de nível 3 como
uma lava e os a fae que fizeram grandes
transformações
uma menina de 12 anos que vivia sob o
regime talibã estudando no paquistão e
começou a escrever no blog a vida
difícil ela levava ela ganhou
notoriedade começou a influenciar
pessoas ficou famosa e sofreu um
atentado talibã tentaram matá la mas não
conseguiram e ela ganhou o prêmio nobel
da paz e conseguiu criar uma grande
transformação no país dela e hoje as
meninas podem estudar em paz
malafaia é um exemplo do empoderamento
do estudo infantil empoderamento das
mulheres
os líderes de nível 3 liberam o
potencial das pessoas eles em poderão as
pessoas
é isso que eles fazem pensar que tem um
tipo de líder que pode ir mais além
são pessoas que tentam resolver os seus
próprios problemas
colocam a vida a serviço dos outros
os líderes de nível quatro servem
valores como empatia compreensão um
entendimento com paixão e altruísmo do
fundo do coração eles colocam a sua vida
a serviço das outras pessoas
eles realmente estão envolvidos o tempo
todo com ações humanitárias trabalhos
sociais ou alguma coisa que tem um
impacto positivo na vida das pessoas
são pessoas bem elevadas pais de nível 4
vamos chamar os seus filhos mostrar ao
mundo os problemas do mundo e vão
perguntar para os seus filhos
meu filho como é que você pode ajudar
com isso aí e eles não vão influenciar
nas respostas
eles só vão fazer os seus filhos
refletir sobre aquilo são líderes
pessoas e organizações como os médicos
sem fronteira que colocam a sua missão a
serviço do outro os médicos sem
fronteira
vou a lugares estão esquecidos ajudar
pessoas que estão passando fome e
miséria ea desnutrição destruição aliás
os líderes de nível 4 normalmente estão
envolvidos
juntando os cacos do que um líder de
nível 1 provocou
porque se você observar um país
subdesenvolvido destruído em guerra em
dificuldade financeira que não cresce
economicamente
você vai encontrar no trono um líder de
nível 1
normalmente os líderes nível 1 causa
confusão nas eleições de vida das
pessoas quando elogia bandeira credos
partidarismos e as pessoas ficam
emocionadas
você já viu esse filme é assim que eles
funcionam e eles colocaram as pessoas
sobre emoção espírito em bordo
eles tomam controle das coisas e
destroem a e precisa dos líderes do
nível 4 para ir lá e fazer os remendos
cuidar dos pobres das pessoas que estão
sem saúde sem educação e que podem
realmente fazer alguma diferença no
mundo
líderes do nível 4
como os médicos sem fronteira servem as
pessoas
você consegue imaginar um tipo de líder
que é mais elevado do que isso os
líderes de nível 5
servem aos melhores valores que um líder
pode ter um coração que valores seriam
esses
se você refletir você vai encontrar
respostas como amor paz e união
liberdade prosperidade fraternidade
líderes de nível 5 revelam a melhor
versão do que pode ser um ser humano
eles não servem as outras pessoas
eles servem aos valores mais elevados
eles deixam que valores como o amor
alegria gratidão perdão de em cada
decisão da sua vida e quando eles fazem
isso eles se transformam em instrumentos
desses valores e quando eles se
transformam em instrumentos desses
valores mais elevados
ele se torna um ponto de luz na
humanidade e consegue impactar a
comunidade a empresa o país e até um dia
inteiro
os pais de nível cinco vãos exemplos
vivos para seus filhos de amor e de
liberdade
são líderes assim como nelson mandela
que libertou o povo negro da opressão
dos brancos libertou os brancos do
próprio ódio
e construir um país unido com todos os
povos no governo
mandela libertou seu povo mandela
construir um país unido em paz líderes
como gandhi que libertou a índia da
opressão dos ingleses e ele libertou os
ingleses da vergonha de humilhar um povo
tão um humilde e ele construiu um país
justo digno e pacificou aquela divisão
que existia no próprio país entre os
indianos porque metade era hindu e
metade gerar um ser humano eles viviam
em conflito quando gandhi morreu
ele deixou um país unido em paz e com o
início de uma democracia
até os vídeos espirituais que já andaram
pela terra oferecer algum caminho para
libertar as pessoas do próprio
sofrimento porque é isso que os líderes
de nível cinco fazem eles praticam amor
a igualdade o desapego à liberdade e
quando eles fazem isso eles libertam as
pessoas todos os problemas do mundo são
causados por líderes do nível 1 e todos
os problemas do mundo podem ser
resolvidos por líderes do nível 5
sabe qual é a boa notícia você pode
escolher ser um líder de nível 5
basta escolher os melhores valores para
guiar suas ações
ter no seu coração
pode parecer muito arrojado você
escolher um valor do nível 5 como amor
por exemplo
mas eu garanto pra você é muito simples
como qualquer habilidade que você tem é
que você desenvolveu você começa aos
poucos você começa com a gentileza no
trânsito com companheirismo no trabalho
com a generosidade na família com
carinho ao relacionar com as pessoas
você não conhece porque todas essas
coisas são pequenas manifestações do
amor e aquilo vai se incorporando e
aquilo vai criando um hábito e quando se
instala no seu coração você não serve
mais amor você é o amor e sabe o melhor
disso tudo os valores moram juntos cada
nível tem os seus valores se você
escolher um valor de um determinado
nível os outros vem no pacote
se você escolher o amor vai vir junto à
liberdade o perdão a fraternidade a
compaixão alegria e sabe o que mais
a felicidade a felicidade mora no nível
aquilo que as pessoas acham que a
felicidade no nível 1 se chama prazer
efêmero e passa rápido
mas a felicidade a realização a
plenitude
você vai encontrar no nível 5 quando
você escolhe o amor
agora que você está consciente disso e
refletiu com o valor você vai escolher
para guiá a sua vida
muito obrigado obrigado
[Aplausos]